new york city mayor bill de blasio is
among those who are calling for governor
cuomo's resignation
the mayor also just announced the city
will start requiring proof of
covid vaccination for a range of indoor
activities including going to a
restaurant or to the gym new york is the
first
major u.s city to introduce a mandate
like this it requires people
to show proof of at least one vaccine
dose
and will be phased in starting later
this month mayor de blasio joins us now
mayor good morning thanks for being here
good morning at the table i i want to
start with
uh with the investigation of governor
cuomo uh
it's no secret there's no loss love loss
between you and governor cuomo but this
this is a very damning report uh as you
saw
the governor came out with a highly
produced response that included a
montage of clips of him
embracing people like uh former
president clinton
what did you make of the governor's
response
the whole thing has been so painful when
you read this report
11 women systematically wronged
11 women confronted by a powerful guy
who could
crush their career and their reputation
and he's the kind of guy that everyone
assumes would
if you crossed him and he harassed them
he assaulted them in several cases it's
not even close
and then he has the audacity to say oh
you know i like to hug
people i mean that's just out of touch
with reality
but it's also profoundly disrespectful
how about saying
i did something wrong i have to atone
for my sins
i need to go and deal with my problems
but he doesn't think he did anything
wrong he says that it's generational
that it could be generational and that
he's not somebody who would
intentionally inappropriately putting
your hand up a woman's shirt and
touching their breast is not
generational
i know plenty of guys who are older who
would never in a million years do that
uh contin talking to 20 something year
old women
asking if they date an older guy and
then leering at them
this is not acceptable behavior it's not
even close the governor's not showing
any indication that he's willing to
resign
what do you think should happen next i
absolutely believe he must resign for
the good of new york state
and our people if he doesn't the
clamor which is universal at this point
democrats and republicans
saying he's got to go is going to win
the day
if he wants to wait for impeachment he
can but it's coming soon in our state
legislation
should he be charged criminally it looks
like it i mean
should he be yeah if you assault a woman
if you do something against her will
sexually that's criminal
and the albany county district attorney
is looking at that and i think he should
be charged let's talk about mandates so
you're going to mandate vaccines for
folks going indoors how does this affect
kids by the way who aren't
eligible for vaccinations look we
welcome kids of course
to restaurants and movie theaters etc
wear a mask that's a smart thing to do
and hopefully soon our five to 11 year
olds will be eligible for vaccination on
top of that but we don't want to
separate families we want families to
enjoy stuff together but in a safe
environment for the folks who work
in restaurants gyms et cetera and for
the customers
here's what i love about it you go into
an environment you know everyone's
in the same place you know everyone's
vaccinated everyone's safe i know it
gives i know as
someone who lives in the city would give
me peace of mind you know going in the
gym everyone's vaccinating
going to the restaurant everyone's
vaccinated but do you think it could
affect tourism
no first of all we're in a city right
now about five million people who have
gotten at least one dose so plenty of
new yorkers ready to go
suburbs even higher levels of
vaccination tourists the people coming
here
more likely that they are vaccinated as
well from all of our studies look
in the end this guarantees the safety of
everyone involved
and it's also going to encourage a lot
of people just
take that next step especially look
young people need
i can say i have two 20-somethings
sometimes young people need a little
encouragement they want to go to
restaurants and bars and concerts
get vaccinated and you're in right mayor
they need a little encouragement
repeatedly sometimes yes
amen amen is it the business or is it
you and the nypd no look first of all
we're we're going to implement this
next few weeks and educate the
businesses support them find out what
they need
to make it work we're not doing any kind
of penalties until the second half of
september
we want this to work for everyone a lot
of business owners have told me thank
you this makes it easier for us we can
tell everyone it's one standard you're
giving them cover
but you're giving them cover in a good
way you've not included an indoor mask
mandate why not yeah because vaccination
is the whole ball game i truly believe
this
one strategy vaccination and masks look
i'm using my mask
lots more places than i ever wearing it
in the green room right
but i also want to say to fully
vaccinated people our doctors say if
you're around fully vaccinated people
you have the option to take it off i
want people get vaccinated to feel they
can live life
fully have a lot of freedom the reward
of vaccination is freedom
tragically if you don't get vaccinated
you're going to be left out
there's a big concert coming central
park august 21st big headlines
celebrating new york you okay with that
yes indeed
yes indeed fully vaccinated same idea
vaccinations the whole strategy to go to
one of these amazing
concerts you have to be vaccinated
they're outdoors
but you still have to be vaccinated and
look i'm hoping
what we're doing with the restaurants
the movie theaters the gyms i'm hoping
other mayors and governors will pick
this up
business leaders are telling me they
like seeing government take the lead it
helps the private sector go farther
so i'm urging all my fellow leaders
around the country that joe biden said
yesterday yeah this is the kind of thing
people should do
this will just help everyone to get
vaccinated and that's how we
beat this god forsaken delta variant
don't take it lightly we gotta defeat it
we wouldn't have been in this position
with the delta variant if people had
gotten vaccinated exactly
mayor bill de blasio thank you for being
here thank you we appreciate it